- Tell me about Big Loo.
I mean, this is--
SELLER: Big Loo is one of the
top 10 pieces in the museum
probably.
- Really?
It is factory seal.
MIKE: Wow.
SELLER: The only
one known to exist.
- This is?
- Mint seal.
Never been opened.
And the person I
bought it from was
a person who designed Big Loo.
What do you estimate
the value of that?
I've bought Big Loos
before missing pieces.
I mean, they were like,
$200-$300 bucks, easily.
Right?
I've got $200 or $300
Big Loos I'll sell you.
MIKE: Yeah, yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
That's what I'd easily get.
Or I got an $18,000
Big Loo I'll sell you.
MIKE: $18,000 Big Loo.
Man, you could have this
or a pan head, Frank.
Yeah.
Can we take Big Loo
out of the cabinet?
Nobody touches Big Loo.
FRANK: Uh oh.
All right.
Can I touch Frankenstein?
Yeah, you can
touch Frankenstein.
MIKE: All right.
I'm going to touch Frank.
SELLER: You can bring him
out of the case if you want.
MIKE: Oh, I'm bringing him out.
I love early Frankenstein stuff.
[music playing]
You know who had him, don't you?
Silver Fox, Dave Ward.
- He did?
He had one in his case next
to his chair in the living room.
One of the toys that Dave had
was this Frankenstein toy.
That's the first time I've
ever seen one of these.
So I have a connection to it.
Not from playing with
it when I was a kid,
but from seeing it
for the first time
at Dave's house and kind
of falling in love with it.
SELLER: You know the
face looks really nice.
MIKE: Yeah.
SELLER: Kind of ugly, but--
What are you thinking on this?
Oh, man it's--
SELLER: $275
He's so cool.
And all it's missing
is the bottom of this.
But you got-- no,
you got the good part.
MIKE: Yeah, but I'd
have to get the bottom.
FRANK: No you don't.
You just put the batteries in
there and just go like that.
All right.
I'm taking it.
- Little piece of scotch tape.
- It's so cool.
It doesn't matter why you
connect with something.
What matters is that
you do connect with it.
What about the
Coke machine here?
Is this something you're
going to hold onto?
Uh, no, I'd probably sell it.
Does it work?
You know, I'm not sure.
MIKE: I can see it's
got the wheel in there.
I think it's complete.
I've got the key for it.
So you've touched it up
or did you buy it like that?
I didn't do anything to it.
So this decal was on there?
Everything was on there?
Yeah, that's exactly
how I bought it.
MIKE: I finally find
something in the museum that's
not related to toys at all.
It's an upright.
It's a cool piece.
So was it local here
where you got it?
Yeah.
I actually bought
it right down here
in Moundsville at the sell.
MIKE: It's mid-50's.
It's a common machine.
The big one that everybody
wants is the model 81 that's
got the long door on the side.
This model is not as
desirable as the 81 or the 44.
But it's original paint.
There's a lot of touch up on it.
But overall, it's in
pretty good condition.
In this condition, I'd
pay a couple grand for it.
$2,000?
- Yeah.
That's where I'd
need to be on it.
Frank, is it OK if I buy this?
- Yeah.
That's not in my
wheelhouse today.
MIKE: OK.
- Put it there, bud.
Appreciate you.
So for $2,000 bucks,
there's a little bit
of room on the back end.
I'm happy with this purchase.
So the soda fountain out
front and this Coke machine
is something I remember
because I grew up in the 1950s.
So it brings back
a lot of memories.
MIKE: Well, you've got--
I mean, after 16
years, you've got
to have seen people walk in
here and just grab their chests
a little bit.
And go, I had that
toy when I was a kid.
When people can have
an emotional reaction
to some of the toys
in here, that's when
I know I did something right.
MIKE: You really did.
And for the community too.
I mean, everybody
that came here.
A lot of people bought gas,
probably stayed at the hotels,
ate at the restaurants.
You're very civic-minded.
I love that.
Well, it was really amazing.
I get a little sad--
[interposing voices]
Hey, I understand.
Was in June--
June was our last month.
We had people come in
from all over the country.
We had a man and a woman
from California drive in here
and she starts balling.
She said I had all of that
when I was a little girl.
That's what makes it
all worthwhile for me.
Seeing them come in
and enjoy all this.
It's almost like the
"Field of Dreams" movie.
If you build it, they will come.
And a lot of people did come.
But I've seen guys
come in and cry too.
MIKE: Really?
I'm that guy.
SELLER: Are you?
I'm the guy that
was so excited when
we got the call from Danielle.
I'm that guy.
[inaudible] is
number one, buddy.
Darn right.
In my book it is.
Well, the fun part of
collecting Marks stories
is the hunt.
I've had 30 years of fun.
Now I'm going to have five years
of fun selling some of them.